representing jeremy hunt this morning
how are you going to pay for all of this
well as you've just heard it's by
cutting taxes on corporation tax you can
actually help inspire economic growth
and that will help boost the coffers of
the treasury now if you cut corporation
tax that could um
put businesses in a position where they
can then afford to give their employees
a pay rise which fuels inflation
it's up to businesses what they do in
terms of uh how they remunerate their
employees but of course what we want to
do is make the uk as competitive as it
possibly can and have the economic
growth that we want because we know
right now as i've just heard you talking
about we face the possibility of your
recession we need to make sure we're
attracting the investment the growth and
the opportunities into this country tax
cuts are a fairy tale according to the
most recent ex-chancellor he said he
said recently he said it about certain
things but i think no one would disagree
with jeremy's approach which is creating
the opportunity for people to be able to
set up businesses in the uk and doing
that through a cutting corporation tax
to the lowest in the g20 that 15 percent
would be the right thing to do for
businesses cross country and if you look
at what we did over the pandemic
cutting a vat cutting business rates you
could see the benefit that that had with
businesses across the country we now
need to employ that for the long term
okay um kickstarting the economy is what
he plans if he is prime minister why is
his campaign not doing as well as last
time it's doing very well it's not it's
doing very well i think one of the
things that i've found and one of the
reasons i'm on jeremy's team is because
he's got a broad tent appeal to people
across the party and across the
membership he's a dignified candidate
he's someone who i think has a great
deal of respect from across the party
and across the membership across the
whole of the country and i think we've
got the numbers to make a really good
showing there's a and hopefully and sold
them into that i mean so they're just
keeping it in their backpack absolutely
people take their time and people want
to come public at their own at their own
time but i think you'll see that today a
remainer of course which is why he lost
last time but he's also as i've just
said he's made a broad tent with people
like myself who are brexiteers with
esther mcveigh who's a brexiteer you
know he is appealing to all wings
because he can actually deliver continue
the program on brexit make sure that we
deregulate make sure that we make
ourselves as competitive as possible and
actually deliver on the some of the
elements of the agenda from 2019. what
did he mean by saying esther mcveigh's
his john prescott to his tony blair well
i think he meant that there's a good
element of teamwork from north and south
from different wings of the party and
i've got that she said she's a
working-class bruiser no i think it's
that she's got great views and great
values and he wants a part of the team i
think that's a very sensible approach to
take because they're not i mean they're
not um what you would expect to be as
bad fellows that you were in the lucid
term of the words of course
that you would expect in politics well i
mean esther described that herself she
said that jeremy's not my natural soul
mate well i think they probably might
become soul mates if this working
relationship um comes off because
actually what i've seen thus far is they
both bring great skills to the table and
i think that's a sensible approach as
well we've got to rebuild trust in
politics we've got to do better in
westminster across across the board i
think what jeremy is trying to do is
attract people from all wings and i
think he's doing that very well
uh how do you feel about the 1922
committee changing the rules so that you
need 20 mps to take part in the first
round i think it's very sensible given
the slate of candidates and the numbers
who are who are expected to uh try and
declare have you got 20 yes have you got
more than 20 uh yes but we don't talk
about numbers have you got 30. i'm not
going to play this game i think we'll
leave it at that but you know you will
see you will see you will see a
nomination from jeremy you need 30 don't
you for the next round
we do yeah do you feel that you're going
to the next i feel extremely confident
about jeremy's ability to uh to do well
him to go into the second round yeah
okay how do you feel about fox hunting
he said that in 2019 he would reverse
the ban on fox hunting well my own view
is that i'm absolutely fine with fox
hunting and it's it's something that
we've discussed and wasted a great deal
of time on discussing before and um
rural rural issues are a matter that we
put a long time ago so
what about him
uh it's his opinion and you know we
don't have to agree with everything
isn't that the benefit of what jeremy's
putting together is that disagreement
discussion allows for a better
conversation better ideas more
innovation that's the things that we
need in government right now because we
haven't had enough of that over the last
two and a half just talking about your
personal opinion you said last week
boris johnson had done appalling damage
to the party
in what way and how can that be reversed
you're going to say with jeremy hunt
being prime minister but in what way is
he of course but actually you know you
know all the candidates are standing are
good decent honest people and i think
they'll bring their own credentials and
ability to to restore that faith listen
we need to be better at listening both
to the parties the membership and the
country we need to make sure that truth
and honesty are at the front of what we
do i don't think that's what boris did
in the in the first instance which is
why i was the first of the 2019 intake
to uh vote against the prime minister
and to put my letter of no confidence in
him but we just got to get back on track
and deal with the issues that actually
really matter and that is the cost of
living that is boosting the economy that
is creating the innovation and
opportunity in this country and i think
jeremy can do that and that's going to
be one of his well that is the center
stage for what he's trying to do
um how's he done a campaign video have i
missed it he hasn't done a campaign
video because what he's doing is going
individually to every member of
parliament he's getting out there he's
doing it in his own way jeremy doesn't
need a shiny video um with you know
music in the background to get his point
across he's doing that face to face with
every single member of parliament
apparently the 1922 committee rules say
that you can spend up to 300
000 pounds let that just sink in at home
300 000 pounds will you be spending
anywhere near that amount or is that
just vulgar given that we've crossed a
living crisis i mean
a campaign cost is a campaign cost i
mean compared to other countries that's
remarkably cheap to be honest but um i
don't know how much it cost to run a
full campaign i'm afraid this is the
first leadership campaign i've taken a
more active hand in so i don't know how
much it costs i don't know how much
you'd end up spending on it okay but do
you think that that's quite a vulgar
figure given uh people are struggling to
hate their homes i mean to select the
next prime minister to make sure they
can get out across the country to make
sure everyone has the opportunity to go
and talk to them no i don't think so
you're not wasting it on a campaign
video
we're not there we go good to talk to
you thank you very much indeed